قد تكون هذه المراه شوكه في انتخابات لن
تكتب النصر للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب في السباق الرئاسي لعام 2024
القضيه الاقرب لاسقاطه هكذا تصنف اذا ما
وجهت التهمه الجنائيه الى ترامب حول دفع
محاميه السابق مايكل كوهن 130 الف دولار
للممثله ستورمي دانييلز ليشتري صمتها قبل
اسبوعين من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي فاز
فيها المرشح الجمهوري على الديمقراطيه
هيلر كلينتون
ادعاءات خرجت للعلن منذ خمس سنوات ولكنها
اليوم تقترب الى حافه المحاكم مع ادلاء
كوهن الذي استحال الى احد الد اعداء ترامب
بافادته امام هيئه محلفين كبرى في نيويورك
في اطار تحقيق حول القضيه ليؤ كد انه ليس
انتقاما وانما يقدم الحقيقه
فبعد سجنه لثلاث سنوات اوضح ماليا انه
تصرف باعاز صريح من الترامب الذي اعاد له
المبلغ فور دخوله المكتبه البيضاوي
النيابه العامه في منهات بدورها استدعت
ايضا ترامب للادلاء بافادته بحسب صحف
امريكيه ما يعني ان توجيها الاتهام الى
الرئيس السابق قد يكون وشيكا
حمله سياسيه شعواء تهدف الى النيل من
المرشح الذي يتقدم باشواط هكذا يصف ترامب
تلك المزاعم حتى حينما ظهرت لاول مره
نفاها مرارا وتكرارا خلال احدى رحلته
الجويه
وذكرت نيويورك تايمز ان التهمه التي قد
توجه الى ترامب هي القيام بتصريحات حسابيه
خاطئه لاخفاء انتهاك لقواعد تمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه لتصبح عودته الى البيت الابيض
شبه مستحيله في العام القادم